[Music]
my name is tamas Shamu and I'm a German
ordnance officer
I know your family and we're very proud
with you I will show the best of love
[Music]
see somebody with a headscarf on but
really I'm just just like any other
officer here there's no difference to me
anybody else that works
you'll have to get a step up for the you
know for the women in our community
I know sometimes they say it's it's not
like it's not likely for them to do it
because maybe because they wear the
scarf they can't I guess you could be
like a role model for people that like
to want to pursue
[Music]
Amell is a very well-educated woman she
has self-confidence she also has
compassion for the people she serves
think on a national basis to dispel some
of those stereotypes this is a huge huge
step for our community for the Arab and
Muslim community in particular are an
inspiration to not just Muslim people
but you know all women and all
minorities whether they wear the hijab
or not no matter what background they
come from I inspire them that's great
and I give them hopes to do this kind of
work but I'm just here to do my job
[Music]